>> The world community should be very much
concerned with what happened
in Haiti -- not with the amount of help that
Haiti just received,
instead how it was -- how it was being distributed
among the Haitian
people.
It was such a mess, such a disarray, and such
a disorganization that a
lot of Haitians die, a lot of people went
looting, and a lot of kids
probably went into some health problems just
because the world
community wasn't ready.
And there was not a central command that would
tell all the world
organizations and medical teams from all over
the world where to go,
what to do, where to send the rescuers and
what -- how to improve the
general situation with people of Haiti.
I recommend the world leaders that there must
be a central command to
the United Nations or to any other source,
so when the need Haiti
disaster occurs anywhere in the world, we
are ready and prepared to
help and could give all our support to a nation
that needs everything.